hail snider so we've had a whole host of
new updates on the justice league snyder
cut in the last couple of weeks
in this video we're going to be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movie
this includes discussing the grace
randolph interview with the main man
himself
a jim lee storyboard that details the
nightmare vision
and a lot more there will be some
spoilers here so if you want to go into
the film without any of the surprises
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the content and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
and all the big dc news every week
as always this is the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition
now let's get into our video on the
snyderka updates
okay so grace randolph from beyond the
trailer dropped an exclusive interview
with zack snyder himself yesterday
that detailed a lot of ins and outs on
the project the 22-minute back and forth
between the two
covered a lot of things that we'd only
heard rumored
and they both went into a lot of detail
on the project
now i know you and you live a very
hectic lifestyle watching the hub all
the time
so if you're too busy to watch the
entire interview then
the first part of this video will be
recapping everything you need to know
about it
i don't want to give anyone a slap in
the grace though so i've been graceful
enough to leave a link to the full
interview in the description
because i'm not a disgrace when it comes
to people at disgrace
damn so they open by discussing the run
time of the film
which will be roughly 214 minutes
however
snyder did hint that it could be even
longer
he didn't want to say specifically what
the exact time was
as some fans might be like well where
did my minute go
warner brothers give us that extra
minute that you clearly cut out
however he did promise that it would be
around about the three and a half hour
mark
so you'll probably end up looking like
robert de niro at the start of the
irishman when you watch it
and come out looking like well robert de
niro at the end of the irishman
now what this leaves room for are
reshoots and additional moments
we're still unsure over whether these
will be added due to the pandemic
ceasing a lot of filming
however we do know that snyder wished to
shoot a scene revealing martian
manhunter
and when running a giveaway he teased a
potential batman
superman and lowest moment whether these
come to fruition or not we don't know
but the fact that the runtime does have
room to be extended
or shortened please not shortened does
mean that
things on the hull can change as for
continuity
this is something that's been wondered
and as of now
we don't really know whether the snyder
coat will replace the whedon one
as the accepted version of the film that
drives the dc eu going forward
there's also things around matt reefs as
batman which has left
more question marks surrounding it than
the riddler's skimpiest uniform
however snyder did state that when they
shot the film in 2016
they had a grand vision for the dcu but
that
since then it's kind of grown into its
own thing whilst he didn't out and out
say whether the film's impact would be
negated by the new direction that things
were going
he did say that he views it as sort of
going off on its own path
separate from the current direction of
the dc eu
snyder confirmed that the upcoming dceu
movies were probably more in line with
what was set up in the theatrical cut
and that if we are looking at everything
we shouldn't view it as a sharp
continuity
that there are different avenues
available he said that the idea of the
multiverse had opened up
a lot of opportunities for the company
to explore and that justice league will
sort of be its own thing classed as the
snyder verse
whilst other things can exist around it
he viewed man of steel
bbs and justice league as being his
trilogy
and that this was purely going to be a
continuation of that story
to him superman was a person that had to
go
on an ark though people have labeled his
version as being an evil superman
and even grace said this in the
interview he did specify that he wanted
a relatable version of the character
that would grapple with humanity
superman was going to be a reflection of
the world at points
and the trilogy was supposed to take him
through his life death
and resurrection in which he would learn
to grow and change to become the best
version of himself
juxtaposing this bruce was supposed to
mirror superman
and snyder said that bruce kind of got
the focus over batman and bvs
because they wanted to show his humanity
to you and how he went to the edge of
the abyss
and managed to come back from it snyder
also brought up matt reeves new batman
and said that he was a fan and was
excited to see what they were going to
do with it
he also stayed that he was a producer on
wonder woman in 1984
and that he had an invested interest in
what patty was doing
zack wants the snyder cut to be viewed
similar to a great comic book run
and he said that the medium allowed him
to do what he wants
but that he was aware there will always
be things that come after his work
which will take place in other
continuities and universes
so it does seem like the snyder cut will
sort of be its own standalone thing
however it is said to introduce darkseid
who we know will be featuring in the new
gods movie
so who knows what will happen personally
i think that with the flash movie being
a flashpoint film
that the best elements of this universe
and the other movies will be brought
together
to reform the continuity and the new
justice league curt may have some of its
elements taken across
whilst others remain purely as part of
zack's vision i think for the moment we
should just enjoy what we have
but i am excited at the idea that the
studio always has the option to take the
universe where they want
grace also asked about wonder woman and
aquaman and how some fans felt that
due to whedon's vision they were
slightly underplayed
many have wondered what the snyder cut
was going to do differently with the
bear
and snyder reiterated that he hadn't
seen a theatrical cut
so wasn't sure of what was different he
did however say that he was excited that
these two loners
were going to join a team setting he
also said that wonder woman had a lot of
things going on
namely what she left behind on a home
and what she would be doing going
forward
wonder woman of course ages very very
slowly
and he said that the timeline of wonder
woman 84 taking place before this movie
allowed for a lot of possibilities again
the theatrical curt
will be more in line with the direction
that the dc eu is going
whereas snyder doesn't really set things
up with a complete trajectory for
aquaman
or his solo movie because snyder has
been given complete creative control
he doesn't want to bring things in line
and therefore doesn't have to stick too
much of the plan
which is allowing him room to explore
snyder also discussed ray fisher
aka cyborg's role and how his
characterization would be
he says in his cut cyborg goes on a huge
journey
and that he represents what it is to
create a community and bring people
together
though it was made in 2016 he said that
these themes are more important now than
ever with the idea of equality and
learning to grow together becoming more
prevalent
in the film we will be discovering
cyborg's origins
and his relationship with his parents
alongside what it truly means to be
human
which are all interesting themes the
director closed out the interview by
stating that
he might even be showing a small clip at
this saturday's upcoming justice con
his panel is due to take place on the
25th of july
at 5 30 pm est and he's going to show
just a tiny tiny clip from the upcoming
movie
and drop a cool little announcement just
for the fans we have no idea what this
is going to be yet but they both sound
really good and i'm very excited
i'll obviously keep an eye out for
whatever these are this weekend
and as always bring you up today with
the movie news as we get it
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the mcu
infinity saga box set to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the updates in the comments
section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of august and the cell will
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay and finally we have a leaked
storyboard that was created by jim lee
which showed a pivotal scene at the end
of the snyder cut
this was to take place in the nightmare
vision setting and it's likely that this
would be how the film
ended if you don't know justice league
was originally called justice league
part 1
and it was going to set up the following
justice league films which would play
out the nightmare version of the
universe in which darkseid would invade
earth
lois would die and then flash would be
forced to travel back in time to warn
everyone of what was coming
the scene which was posted by the
cultured nerd picks up five years after
the events of justice league
and sort of acts as a flash forward
which the following film would
inevitably set up
the text is a little bit difficult to
read but we have a transcript
which says the following five years
later
sand dunes smoldering solar pits
gothic spires rising from the desert
once this was gotham now like the rest
of the earth
it belongs to darkseid
coming over the june post-apocalyptic
batman
as seen in bvs and also definition's
fancy dress costume
with a ragtag army of rebels the
surviving members of the justice league
walk over the rise of a dune to see the
dilapidated wayne manor
batman leads them flash drags what's
left of cyborg behind him
bruce looks up in the sky grimly we need
to get inside before
night is coming so not only does it
sound like
the best batman impression of all time
it also sounds like a really
really cool way to end the movie and i
would absolutely love to see this play
out on screen
i think it might even be what snyder was
talking about when he said that the
continuity should be viewed as something
that will be separate
it doesn't look like dc are heading down
the nightmare vision route
but anything is possible at this moment
in order to get this scene done
they would need to get ben back which is
an unknown quantity at this point
and there really could be a number of
things that could happen in regards to
the film
in addition to this we also got a
mock-up of the original steppenwolf
design
amongst how his base was going to look
this really excites me
as it teases the kind of thing that we
could be seeing in the upcoming film
and at this moment it really feels like
dc are putting that all in to deliver
the best film possible
no matter what i love that there's going
to be no compromises and
continuity to really worry about so that
zack can deliver his complete vision
instead of worrying about setting up
future films i do think that dc
will still do nods to this movie in the
future but even if they don't
it's gonna be great to see his vision on
the big screen
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the updates and what you
hope to see in the movie
comment below and let me know and i just
want to give a huge thank you to
everyone for getting me to 300 000
subscribers
it's been an incredible journey i want
to thank every one of you
and thank you so much for joining
everyone every week you're the best
you're the best now if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and it's a
thank you you get access to content
early
when it come chatters after the show
either follow us and heavy spoilers or
click on the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep a date
with us so hopefully we see you over
there
but if not tell you what mate you can go
do one i'm just kidding come back
come back please come back anyway you've
been the best and i'll see you next time
cheers
you